hey guys this episode is inspired by
your comments on a previous middle
ground make sure you stick around to the
enemies we want to tell you about how
you can be even more involved enjoy the
episode because people are anti sex
that's why we're having I am process I
am not ashamed if you're pro sex you're
Pro pornography that's how that's by
your definition well that's exactly
right that's why we're gonna agree to
disagree
hi I'm buck and I'm a human rights
activist and pro a porn hi I'm Abigail
and I'm an aspiring physician and I'm
pro porn hi I'm Riley I'm an adult
performer and I'm pro porn hi my name is
JK I am a porn addiction recovery coach
and I'm passionate about helping men who
struggle with compulsive sexual
behaviors hi my name is Maria I have run
a youth organization and we educate on
this issue my name is Nicole I'm 21
years old and headed to law school next
year I have been a first-hand witness of
the devastating FX porn can have in
personal relationships
can I have my anti porn people on the
left and my pro form people on the right
please I have watched porn
I've watched porn in the past and I
think I've watched more than my fair
share of it to the point that it changed
my life right now I don't because I'm at
a point where it's been a decade I won't
be going back to it i watch porn I also
produce porn what a great medium to use
to help to explain to people different
kinds of bodies different kinds of
sexualities different ways that people
fantasize about things in a healthy
manner
I started off watching porn as young as
12 out of curiosity and eventually it
led into my sexual exploration and
loving my body so I watch porn on a
daily basis to you know satisfy myself I
don't watch porn it's not like I don't
think about sex or anything like that
but that's just something I've only seen
cause destruction and the relationships
that I've been close to you and I've
purposely stayed away from it don't you
think they're they already had a problem
before the pornography sure yeah how can
don't you do you think that pornography
just pushed it forward and made the
situation worse I don't think it's the
cause I think it's a symptom of the
cause it certainly pushed for it into
issues of deceit of mistrust and broken
relationships that certainly weren't
helped by an exposure to pornography
what if you saw a healthy relationship
around pornography would that change
your mind I think amazing relationship
is subjective also direct that to me um
the thing is professionally I have just
never seen it we do have cases where
they thought they were open to it
and one of them just got addicted to it
what is addiction addiction is when it
starts interfering with other aspects of
your life when it interferes with your
career when it interferes with your
finances when it interferes with your
erection
I couldn't masturbate for years unless I
was viewing pornography do you think
shame has something to do with the
reason why people feel that they get
addicted I get shamed all the time for
my career but what I believe is that
people have created this idea that
pornography is negative pornography is
bad people use these at too
lame or springboards to say well he used
alcohol and he watched pornography so
that must be the reason if that wasn't
there
if porn wasn't there the relationship
could be saved high-speed Internet
pornography in my opinion escalates the
decline of any relationship
I developed a sense of entitlement
towards certain sexual acts I expected
that a woman in a relationship at may
should be willing to give [ __ ] or
should wants to have anal sex and these
things came before what she actually
enjoyed it caused the women a lot of
pain it caused them to look at their
bodies and go like well he likes me for
everything else but like he's totally
not into it or he's not with me when we
were having sex because he's somewhere
else imagining that all of that when I
measured it and I look back it just came
back to porn
I got to a point where I could not have
sex or maintain an erection unless I was
imagining a scene from some porn that I
watched three months ago and sadly I'm
not the only one it took so long in fact
for me it took 18 months and this
involved a lot of work to know that it
takes 18 months the journaling before I
could have a regular sex life again
do you see that there's a way that we as
pornography creators could create
content that would help them it's Noble
I wish that I years ago I tried to
believe that but once I realized how big
the porn industry machine is I just
realized that that is not going to be
the solution I'm yet to meet a client
who told me like yeah JK I downgraded my
porn to missionary I started watching
vanilla stuff no because it no longer
starts with the vanilla stuff and you
all know that I walk 100% agree with you
there is bad pornography I will one
understand but that said and that
doesn't make all of it
that it's causing people to have
erectile dysfunction now me I'm a
transgender man so I was born a woman
and I became a man I kept my vagina I
kept my vagina for a reason but that
said I use it in within my pornography
and I use that specifically to teach the
world about sexual experiences with a
man like myself and it is sex
educational on some level it's also a
body educational but the question that I
have for all of you would be what are we
doing about the 11 for the 11 year olds
who can one moment are playing for
tonight on minecraft and the next they
are watching someone of your gender
which they have no understanding of what
it is and using that to determine what
their sexual identity is going to be
what are the ethics of it is it an all
cost I must educate people when I was
eight I never got to see anything like
that so guess what I did when I was
eight I cut my arms I tried to commit
suicide I hated myself because I was a
man with a vagina at eight years old
that was horrifying for me now if I was
eight-year-old and I got to pick up my
phone and I got to see me I would be
like actually wow I can actually be this
man but I never got that opportunity at
eight years old now I agree with you
pornography for an eight-year-old is
probably not the best thing in the world
but let's talk about the parents if I
had an eight-year-old I would never let
that eight-year-old have a phone or me
on the Internet so interesting to say I
was wanted to run over here so
interesting I actually remember this
story in like the middle of the talk a
mom she stood up basically and raised
her hand and grabbed a my her son who
was eight years old he had google sex so
he was curious he wanted to know you
know like any other kid but what he
found them was porn and I would argue
that the mainstream pornography does not
actually show sex if you know what I
mean he was not so upset about like what
he had seen he was more upset about the
thing that he had seen he thought this
is what my parents do to each other in
bed but why is he fearful that's the
thing that I want to understand why kids
are fearful of sexual interaction I
noticed in Sweden in Norway and
particularly much more open about bodies
what I note what I thought to myself was
well what if children on some level
we're talking we're taught about sex as
up
positive thing as beautiful things but
that's kind of the I think perhaps
you're missing the point of the story
because he was looking for sex yeah you
know she was it was but what he saw was
not what he exactly
I would assume and I would guess that it
was quite aggressive I think I want to
add on to something you were saying you
have to have some level of maturity to
watch it I remember coming across a
video where a girl was masturbating with
a sharpie marker and I thought oh it
looked she she was having fun let me
grab a sharpie marker let me try this
made absolutely no sense I remember
doing in I remember thinking what is
this like this makes no sense so me
doing my research I realized certain
masturbation techniques and then I
realized oh pornography isn't real like
that's this is just a show and
unfortunate realization and I'm not
saying that's the cause of the addiction
or whatever but there should be some
level of understanding yeah so I said no
to the prompt because I currently did
not have a sex life but I've definitely
experienced emotional intimacy with
somebody who was addicted to pornography
and absolutely experienced hurt within
that of him not being honest about the
fact that that was something he
struggled with and that similar to you
it sounds like had expectations of me
that I couldn't fulfill and that I
didn't know where they were coming from
until a year into the relationship so
yeah I think pornography can affect
intimacy without affecting particularly
a sex life the stigma around porn is too
negative
when I see when I meet kids and youth
especially like in classrooms is that
the stigma and the kind of shame and the
guilt is exactly what is kind of
hindering the conversation I'm all about
like lifting that off of their shoulders
to have you know the conversation be
open and honest that's why I think it's
so important that this is happening you
know that we're talking about this I
believe the Sigma should be negative I
think pornography is simple the reason I
did come over and said it's too negative
is because especially in the church
there's the Sigma of shame that comes
after asking for forgiveness I just
think that there should be an easier way
to move on and grow out of that
experience so we've talked a lot about
the way that stigma and consumption
affects the consumer but we haven't
really talked much at all we'll have
been sitting here about labor and the
people who make porn and from my point
of view I see firsthand so much the way
that stigma against porn affects the
lives and the safety of porn performers
it is near impossible to get a decent
ob/gyn it is hard to find a mental
health care professional who will not
pathologize you for your choice of
occupation it leads to a well-known
phenomenon people losing their families
just by virtue of what they do for a
living
it's the palpable discrimination that
sex workers of all kinds face because of
this kind of negative stigma I know this
was a good one to watch from the outside
this is the first moment standing there
that I was able to see like okay Wow
because I could feel it this time
instead of just listening I feel the
human part and that's why I say that the
stigma hurts that's what I see the
stigma hurts but the stigma needs to be
there because sometimes it's the only
way I can get my point across right so I
think what you're saying is that to help
demographic that you need to help it
needs to have that stigma but stigma on
any way shape or form is not good for
anybody
once stigma is there it's just gonna
create a negative space I agree with you
don't ever have to accept what I do only
thing I ask for is respect and respect
means no stigma while I would maybe not
give you exactly what you want as
respect for your profession I absolutely
respect you as a person and I think that
your opinions while totally wrong are
good
you have the right to have that opinion
our society needs better sex education
don't just teach them how sex works
biologically teach the children about
consent and autonomy over their bodies
and communication with their partners
and how to do that in a healthy way
emotional intelligence is one of the
things that is lacking among men who
watch a lot of pornography society the
ways we were raised Disney and then
pornhub and then you get this messed up
emotional intelligence thing you know it
all conflict it's true because I was
born as a woman I was not born as a man
its dominance taking that's what we see
as masculinity and I totally disagree
with that it's very toxic and so we do
need to talk about that but for myself
and my particular porn and my desire to
create education around it was
specifically targeted to people like
myself because I didn't have sex till I
was in my 30s because I was too freaked
out about my body and too freaked out
about how people would feel about me and
so I was not comfortable sexually so I
knew once I became sexually comfortable
thank God for that because that gave me
a space to be the man I am today told me
from home but I think we basically all
agree that at the end of the day we
recognize sex is something that should
be beautiful that should be a form of
expression just who you're expressing it
to and when you express it
kind of disagree on I think all of these
views were necessary to create something
new onst and I hope that it improves the
mental landscapes of the folks who
consume what we produce
I love how respectful of a conversation
that was that was awesome yeah I think
this is one of the best representations
of what no what I'm supposed to be as
you guys know Jubilee we are trying to
create a movement of changemakers for
human good and that means you guys you
guys are the movement so we love hearing
from you send us all of your ideas good
ideas of that ideas are like the okay
ideas we love reading them as always
subscribe like us on facebook follow us
on Instagram and we'll see you next time
[Music]